so many times I get a message and people
will say Patrick have the most
incredible product in the world that if
we were to partner together it would
sell billions of dollars and I always
have questions back for this because
there are many great products in the
world listen not one or two there are
millions of great products in the world
that lack a marketer and a promoter and
it makes make you what I mean by this
you know when when you think about the
world of boxing and the nineties boxing
used to be very very big because there
was a guy who made more money than any
of the boxers and fighters that guy's
name was Don King Don King was a
promoter boxing was on the earth
everybody was watching boxing because of
how good of a promoter he was if you go
today and if you look at fighting today
you will see there's boxing we still
have pride if you look at pride some of
you guys that follow MMA these we pride
fighting before UFC pride flop UFC is
crushing it and boxing has dropped out
why is UFC crushing it because the best
promoter it's not the best product pride
had the best fighting because there was
no limits on how the fights were right
and boxing has the most talent because
they're very talented with their boxing
UFC's doing well because of one guy Dana
White is the greatest promoter amongst
the three you take Dana White out you
UFC does not exist all the credit goes
to Dana White's promoting skills on
every time and he's always there if you
look at any fight that happens he's
always there he's all over the world
he's not sleeping and just kind of
waiting for somebody else to that when
there is an opportunity to have a fight
and the two fighters he's in the middle
you seen that takes a lot of work a lot
of effort Dana White does that you go
back to WWE which stood for what world
resident entertainment Vince McMahon was
an incredible promoter of a product
there was other wrestling he's not the
founder of wrestling wrestling used to
be Don Mario matter of fact who each to
do the rest and wasn't it like a who was
it before that it was a
no there was something else even prior
to that there was something that was you
said it came from a Hispanic weech
Elliot Mucha lucha lucha libre if you
look at arresting Rustin wasn't founded
by Vince McMahon he was just the best
promoter this can go with product
placement
Apple Apple was all about Steve Jobs
being incredible at promoting there are
times where he never had the product
fully prepared but he was such an
incredible promoter tens of thousands of
people would come to the product launch
and the products not finalized it's not
finished but he was that incredible
promoter I phone lines thousands of
people lined up for a week to be the
first person to say I got the iPhone
people pay a 16 year old kid $30,000 to
stand a line for two weeks to say I was
the first person to get an iPhone and
that person exchanged places with them
because I kid stood there for two weeks
these things happen because somebody is
very very good at promoting the product
so what do you think about okay I want
to become a great promoter I want to
become a great marketer there are three
things great promoters and marketers
have in common one they have unwavering
enthusiasm their energy is incredible
everybody wants to see this person's
energy enthusiasm that they have to they
are very much about painting a very
specific pictures also almost like a an
artist a pane of Michelangelo that has
the details you know when you when you
read a book and it says you know as he
was walking in the hallway he heard the
sound in the backyard of the water
dropping and all of a sudden he heard
something for him and he looked behind
him it was a cat a promoter is great I'm
telling that specific details I'm
painting the picture that you and I see
this is gonna be the greatest honor of
all time this is gonna be the greatest
fight of all time they've gripped great
promoters and number three number three
they're the best storytellers they are
the best at telling stories
so one unwavering enthusiasm to specific
details of painting a picture that you
and I can touch it and then three
they're great storyteller so the next
time somebody says I have the most
incredible product in the world that is
going to become a billion-dollar
opportunity
you need a great promoter because many
great products have been buried in the
cemetery of great products that lacked a
great motor and a marketer learn how to
become a great promoter marketer you'll
notice your business will do very well
it's my message to them please if you
got any questions comment on the bottom
subscribe to this channel thanks for
watching